okay as promised we are back with
Predator versus Wolverine part two and
then we have to wait another month for
the third
issue so what this does is much like the
previous issue it picks up kind of in
the modern day when Wolverine is facing
off against a predator and then it jumps
back to a previous point in which they
fought now what is cool about this
normally I wouldn't cover it but what is
cool about this is that this guy's just
clinging to the side of a building and
as you guys can probably tell there's a
lot lot of just callbacks to like the
original Predator with Arnold
Schwarzenegger right like that's really
what this is him clinging to the side of
a mountain trying to give himself a
chance to recover and so on and so forth
but one of the other things to know is
that in the present right now Wolverine
has his adamantium claws but when we
jump back to the point where the last
video ended we jumped back to the 1960s
when he was on team X before he got us
adamantium and so that's one of of the
things to know now he is rapidly
approaching that moment but in the here
and now one of the things to remember is
every time Wolverine went on a mission
for team X his memories were wiped and
so somewhere between the previous issue
and this issue his memories of his first
encounter with a predator were
completely wiped away so for him this is
all new now one of the cool things
that's given here by Benjamin Percy and
I love the way he does this he kind of
gives us a quick little rundown of what
team X is and for those of you guys who
are unfamiliar with it it's explained
like that right team X was a dirty crew
that did Dirty Jobs assassinate a
politician blow up a dam sees an oil
platform take out a cartel all in the
name of geopolitical subversion it's a
wet workor team right it's a Black Ops
Team that's really all these guys are
but in this instance they were sent to
this part of the world in order to stop
a coup now what he says here is he says
we found ourselves instead in the middle
of a borderless war we were already down
to four against their five what they
were I didn't know like everyone else on
team X my memories were regularly
deleted but I had carried this weapon
with me over the years what he's talking
about here is like the smart dis of the
original Predator he just had it in his
possession presumably after his memories
were wiped he woke up with it and then
maybe used it once or twice realized
what it was and was like I'm going to
hold on to this but didn't quite recall
how he actually got it but what he says
is it was like a are a relic of pain I
understood two of us somehow shared and
so this is when he grabs this thing
right activates it and throws it at the
predator and because it's so dangerous
right like this thing can take Predators
out and that's what's so cool is because
it operates like a boomerang right you
throw it it hits his Target and then you
basically recall it back the funny thing
here is he tells like Maverick and the
rest of Team X to basically back out
right to get out of there as fast as
they can but Wolverine knows enough to
know these guys are not to be trifled
with right the very fact that they just
kind of stumbled on to these guys and
being unaware of the fact that they were
there is what tips them off because
remember even though Wolverine does not
have adamantium he does have all his
other powers enhanced senses and all
that kind of stuff he couldn't detect
these guys which means they're not to be
trifled with and so he's like we got to
go we got to back out we got to
basically REM Marshal ourselves figure
out what we're going to do and how we're
going to confront this but Sabertooth
ever the man who loves death and
destruction is like nope we're going to
unload on these guys with a minigun so
like Jesse Ventura from Predator 1 right
so literally he just starts spring the
whole area down with a minigun in
probably the most saber-tooth way ever
and in fact one of the Predators gets
the upper hand and basically Gets behind
him but if you talk to anybody who knows
anything about saber-tooth there's two
things to understand number one
saber-tooth as he's been depicted in
recent years leading up to fall of x was
nowhere near as amazing as he was in the
80s when he was just like this hyper
violent crazy guy who would just tear
people apart like it was oh God I loved
I love Sabertooth not so much in the
original Iron Fist comic but like when
he was part of Chris claremont's Xmen
that's when he was at his best but the
second thing is Sabertooth just has
blood lust this guy lives for war and
chaos and pandemonium it's his thing and
so that's why even though like this
Predator stabs him through back with
like a Smart Stick you have him who just
like pulls a dagger and stabs a predator
through the stomach lifts it up and
while both of them are seemingly taken
out this Predator is basically dunzo and
so at that point like Jackson Maverick
and Wolverine bolts right now they're
not like running out of cowardice it's
like again it's just getting themselves
to a place where they can Marshal their
forces and they can say we need to
ensure that we're in a spot where these
things whatever they are can only attack
us from a direction that we can see
right because the last thing you want to
do it's just being like a killbox right
where like you can be hit from any
direction right that's the last thing
that you want and so just to clarify
right there's two Predators down there's
three more left right now that's the
crazy thing that I love about team X is
because the fact that they could take
out two so fast it's believable it's
absolutely believable that this team
could do it just given how prodigious
they are just to give you guys
perspective wolver rain was so capable
that in Marvel Comics he's actually the
guy that helped to train the black
widows in the Red Room right that's how
good this guy is and so one of the
things that happens here is poor Jackson
Man Jackson is going to make it Jackson
doesn't make it right because as they're
bolting one of the Predators lowers down
this kind of rope right like a noose
essentially snatches up Jackson
Jackson's head comes clean off body
comes crashing down to the ground and
literally like you just have Wolverine
and Maverick who were just shooting up
into the air because one of the things
to know is that yes if they're given a
moment to actually analyze their
surroundings they would likely be able
to see these guys if for no other reason
than the fact that while you do have a
cloaking device for these Predators
again much like you've seen in the
movies it refracts light it bends light
as opposed to making them truly
invisible so all you have to do is just
find like where it looks like the forest
is moving but like in this gigantic
Forest they would likely kill you before
you could actually figure out where they
were right just moving around so fast
and whatnot right it's why the Predators
right the yaa they're like the perfect
Hunters it's just maybe the Xenomorphs
are better let me know which one you
guys think are the better Hunters
technically Predators hunt Xenomorphs as
a right of passage so you could argue
Xenomorphs are the better hunters and
predators regardless it doesn't matter
the thing about this is that like once
this massive explosion goes off you
basically have Maverick and Wolverine
who were taken unawares one of the
Predators tries to use this as a moment
to attack now one of the things that I'm
not 100% sure how I feel about this in
the traditional Predator Mythos they are
Hunters of Honor right they are beings
that hunt for Honor unless you're
talking about Adrien Brody's uh
Predators where like they hunt for sport
and they don't really care about the
honor of it depending on that kind of
faction Civil War that's going on
whatever but I have a hard time
believing that a predator would
incapacitate these guys with a massive
explosion and then go directly after
them I would prefer to believe and this
is kind of my viewpoint on it I would
prefer to believe that a predator would
want to take them out in one-on-one
combat but again you know I guess it's
just kind of determin it based on the
Mythos and how you perceive it and so on
but Maverick realizes that one of these
guys is running up on him pulls out a
pistol just in time to spray these guys
down and that's it now that's where
things are a little murky because of
course as we know with a predator Mythos
just shooting it with a bullet isn't
really enough to take one of these
things out and shooting it with multiple
bullets wouldn't necessarily be the case
right like one they're incredibly dense
and incredibly strong and two they have
the ability to heal using their own
technology so while it wouldn't
necessarily kill this guy per se it
would be enough to incapacitate him and
the very least send him running but
regardless this guy's killed and so what
you have is Maverick and wol Rain who
take up refuge in an old Mayan Temple
now what's crazy about this is now it's
two on two right two predators and then
Maverick and and Wolverine and so once
they get into this Temple they find all
these explosives around right TNT the
whole nine yards and they're all kind of
just set to detonate right I mean it's
just like detonators rigged these things
things and so on and so forth then
they're met with the general who's
actually the one orchestrating the coup
now it's not a great big huge thing that
goes on here with the general it's just
long enough to establish everybody's
motivation that the general and his
troops retreated to this place once the
Predators showed up because the
Predators were just like like cutting a
swath through these guys right I mean
just absolutely crushing these guys
that's all it was and so this is one of
those instances where the enemy of my
enemy is my friend now one of the things
I also want to point out here is again
you can tell that Wolverine's claws are
currently bone claws they're not
adamantium yet it's the reason why he
hasn't just so easily crushed these
these Predators because I would have to
believe right like wolver rain with an
with adamantium claws and an adamantium
skeleton plus his healing Factor
fighting a predator would be Child's
Play right it would be no contest which
really begs the question what's going on
in the modern day between the predator
and wolver rain and this fight that's
actually leading wolver rain to like B
his time and like heal himself and so on
and so forth have the Predators just
become that much more advanced and the
adamantium doesn't matter but regardless
right in the here and now right at the
time this story is being told we
basically have these guys who were just
kind of standing there just monitoring
and just keeping an eye out in case they
see anything and one of them asked the
question like do you think maybe they
left right maybe they won't come after
us this poor bastard gets his head blown
apart right like the shoulder Cannon
just annihilates this dude's head one of
them pops his shield like you straight
up Captain America comes lunging into
this place and like kill like just takes
these guys out right just like that
annihilates these guys and so following
that you have Wolverine and Maverick
that leave the smart disc sitting out
there on a piece of rock for the
Predators to locate and then basically
attain what's crazy about this is they
rigged the entire place to explode right
they rigged the whole place to blow up
that sure they get their device back but
then it's just like beep beep beep beep
like all these bombs are getting ready
to go off and the whole place gets blown
to Smither now the reality here is that
Professor Thorton the guy who runs
Weapon X he doesn't really care about
Predators probably doesn't even really
know that they existed or anything like
that and if he does he's seemingly not
too concerned about it but you would he
probably would be if he knew about them
right weapons plus is always in the
business of like finding some kind of
new super soldier some technology that
can be used for profit right creating
wolver rain so on and so forth and so
wolver rain actually does the general is
solid where he says like he details
Professor thoron the mission went off
without a hitch there every anybody that
we were supposed to kill is dead right
like everything's cool nothing could
have survived that only for us to find
out that at least one of the Predators
did now at that point switch over to
Alberta Canada at the weapon x facility
right now the reason why Weapon X is in
Alberta Canada is because the weapon x
program at that point was a joint
venture between the United States CIA
and Canada's Department H right they're
kind of superhero initiative to a degree
and so that's why it's based out of here
but this as most everybody knows is
where Wolverine under goes the
adamantium bonding process and so what
happens is a predator shows up and then
like kills one of the guards the other
one's just kind of like what in the
world is going on and then this guy wow
right gets like a dagger to the throat
and then while he's laying there the
Predator just like dumps that Gunk all
over his face right and it's just like
damn Benjamin Percy dude that's hardcore
man like damn like that's just that's
not even that's not even like achieving
a mission that's just being a dick so
then the predator in turn goes through
and takes out every single person in the
weapon x facility now this is the cool
thing right here's a really cool thing
that you could argue here right we don't
know if this story is actually in
continuity in Marvel Comics you could
potentially argue that it is depending
on how Benjamin Percy wants to end it I
would argue it's not right it's just
kind of a story that exists out there
but if Marvel says that it is in
continuity the fact that the Predator
Slaughters everybody here and then
escapes that kind of fits in perfectly
with the Wolverine Mythos because when
Wolverine escaped basically everybody
was destroyed and so there wasn't really
any actual person out there that could
recall and state explicitly what had
happened at least as far as I'm
concerned Abraham Cornelius Carol Hines
Professor Thorton they were the three
who ran the program somebody correct me
if I'm wrong which I'm sure you guys
will right you guys love waiting until I
get something wrong it's like actually
Robb you know but like let me know right
like let me know if I'm wrong about that
I don't think I am I think they all died
during the original Weapon X Breakout by
wolver rain and they weren't able to get
him back but this kind of fits in
perfectly with everything but regardless
this Predator smashes into the place and
as he gets up to Wolverine he's actually
getting the adamantium bonding process
right like it's being bonded to a
skeleton so seemingly this Predator is
going to leave alone right because again
predators don't really kill unarmed foes
and while it may be pissed off about the
fact that Wolverine killed all of his
friends at the end of the day it is all
about the honor of the hunt so likely
it'll walk away and it'll wait until
Wolverine pops back up again and the two
of them will fight which begs the
question what happens when these two
fight and Wolverine has an adamantium
skeleton I'd bet all the money in my
pockets to all the money in your pockets
they're going to fight in Japan with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end if you guys need to
get caught up on on Predator versus
wolver rain make sure you click this
link to the playlist and I will catch
you all later peace